Speaker 1: All right. Let's start today
with news out of Russia and Ukraine.
These headlines are sort of unbelievable. I've
been stopped short of calling them Kafkaesque,
but it's almost appropriate. The Associated
Press reports that Vladimir Putin,
the Russian president, has declared martial
law in the annexed regions of Ukraine. Now,
that headline might make sense if that there
was really an annexation that took place. What
we're really talking about is occupied regions of
Ukraine in which Putin is claiming sovereignty,
but in which there really is no sovereignty.
And so it's kind of a weird thing to say. I'm
declaring martial law in parts of a different
country, which is fundamentally what Putin is
doing. But of course, his perspective would be a
different one. Let's look at a little bit of this
article and we'll talk about the reasons for this
and the implications and sort of what comes next.
Associated Press Once again, Russian President
Vladimir Putin declared martial law Wednesday
in the four regions of Ukraine that Moscow
annexed and gave additional emergency powers
to the heads of all regions of Russia. Putin
didn't immediately spell out the steps that
would be taken under martial law. I think we
can guess some of them, but said his order was
effective starting Thursday. His decree gives law
enforcement agencies three days to submit specific
proposals and orders the creation of territorial
defense forces in those four annexed regions. The
the statement here from Putin, again, it's it's
all extremely dystopian. Quote, We are working
to solve very difficult, large scale tasks to
ensure Russia's security and safe future to
protect our people. Those who are on the front
lines are undergoing training at firing ranges,
and training centers should feel our support
and know that they have our big great country
and unified people behind their back.
Sounds a little bit Trumpy, quite frankly.
The Associated Press article also adds The
upper house of Russia's parliament was set
to quickly seal Putin's decision to impose
martial law. Again, the regions we're talking
about are Donetsk, Kherson, Luhansk and Zappa
is here. Draft legislation indicates it may
involve restrictions on travel and public
gatherings, tighter censorship and broader
authority for law enforcement agencies.
Think about the evil genius of this write
up. It's not even your country. You say, Oh
yeah, we're annexing these parts of the country.
It's not formally done. And I understand that
when a country is annexing part of another,
the idea of formality, often what you're talking
about is just years of it sort of being under
the control. And then you say, Well, I guess
now it's kind of annexed. That definitely has
not happened. And then you say now that this is
part of our country and we've annexed this, we're
going to impose further restrictions and further
repress and suppress reporting from the area,
etc.. The belief there's a few different beliefs,
sort of like most likely lowest hanging fruit
priorities here. One would be legal cover for
the wave of repressions that are certainly that
is certainly to come as absurd as that cover is.
Hey, this is Russia now. And so now we're imposing
martial law. The other aspect of this and a couple
of people wrote to me said, you know, David, it's
kind of silly to say you're like imposing martial
law in any kind of formal way because it's a war
zone. And so by definition, it's all kind of under
the control, at least ostensibly of the military.
So to now declare the martial law, it's it kind
of is under a de facto martial law type situation
because it's militaries fighting each other. We're
looking at a forced mobilization of Ukrainians in
the area to start getting the Ukrainians out.
And this is by many reasonable assessments,
a war crime. But by pretending that this is now
Russia, that these four regions are part of Russia
and that the individuals there are Russian,
because remember, he's, quote, annexed it.
It's I don't I don't want to call it plausible,
but it's sort of is a 1% attempt at claiming that
what you're doing is just the governance of your
own country rather than an alleged war crimes. So
it's bonkers and it's crazy. And of course,
we continue to wonder about what is the end
game here. There does not seem to be a face saving
offramp for Vladimir Putin here. And increasingly,
the questions among the United States and Western
allies continue to be how far do we allow this to
go and for how long? And what are the sort of red
lines at which point different interventions would
happen for how long and to what degree and in what
particular ways do we again use Western allies,
naito, etc.? Sort of these Venn Venn circles
of those individual groups continue to fund and
supply Ukraine and. At what point do we imagine
that the circumstances may change? And there
aren't really good answers to that in the U.S.,
as is often the case. The conversation becomes
what I call toxically partizan. And what I mean
by that is, of course, if different individuals
with different worldviews would have different
opinions about what should be done in Russia,
obviously more isolationist individuals would
say, we should do nothing. We shouldn't even
send money sent note don't send arms and nothing
at all. Don't send legs, don't send anything.
That's a joke, by the way. Others would say, well,
we we send money, but not arms or we send money
and arms, but absolutely nothing beyond that.
Well, what about training? And then, of course, at
the very far end of that would be sort of boots on
the ground. The unfortunate thing is that when I
say it's become toxically partizan, you have many
right wingers who seek only to attack Joe Biden,
who take the position that Biden is just wasting
money in Ukraine. Now, a lot of these same people
earlier were saying Biden hasn't done enough to
protect the Ukrainian people and Russia never
would have even invaded if Trump was president.
So you can't really get anywhere with about 60 to
70% of people on this issue. I'm really willing to
entertain reasonable perspectives. I don't want to
say from both sides, but regardless of political
ideology, I'm willing to entertain reasonable
perspectives that will both not allow Russia to
just walk all over whoever they want to walk over,
while also not committing or involving
the United States in a way that would be
either counter counterproductive or not
particularly appropriate, given that we
should not be the world's police. Any I'm willing
to entertain any reasonable ideas that fall under
that umbrella. If you have any as to what
this should look like, feel free to email me.